sí
bienvenidos a el debate de france 24 soy
marina colorado representantes de las 35
capitales del continente americano y
otras 5 ciudades invitadas del mundo se
reunieron el lunes 17 de agosto de
manera virtual en el segundo foro de
autoridades locales del ambiente porque
la importancia de que los gobiernos
locales estén involucrados en las
decisiones climáticas pues porque vamos
encaminados hacia un mundo totalmente
urbanizado en latinoamérica ya el 80% de
la población reside en ciudades y cada
vez queda más claro que la manera en la
que hemos diseñado estas no es
compatible con un futuro saludable y
sostenible las ciudades son parte del
problema pero son también parte de la
solución este evento forma parte de la
llamada ruta santiago glasgow que busca
conectar el liderazgo ambiental de la
capital chilena que presidió la cumbre
sobre cambio climático de la onu el año
pasado la cop 25 al liderazgo de la
ciudad escocesa de glasgow que albergará
la cob 26 en 2021 a través de distintos
eventos y reuniones climáticas
resaltar el crucial papel de los
gobiernos locales y regionales en ayudar
a que los países logren alcanzar los
objetivos climáticos acordados en parís
en 2015 para mantener el aumento de la
temperatura del planeta por debajo de
los 2 grados centígrados y así frenar el
calentamiento global
de este segundo foro de autoridades
locales del ambiente de las américas
salió la declaración de santiago en la
que reconocen que el cambio climático es
sin duda el principal reto al que se
enfrenta la humanidad para conocer más
acerca de este texto de compromisos
ambientales tenemos cuatro invitados en
el programa de hoy
jose luis samaniego director de la
división de desarrollo sostenible y
asentamientos humanos de la comisión
económica para américa latina y el
caribe de la cepal
isabel aguilera subdirectora de medio
ambiente de la ciudad de santiago maría
josé avendaño directora de ambiente de
ciudad de guatemala
y por último verónica arias directora
ejecutiva del ccc 35 bienvenidos y
gracias por su tiempo en france 24 antes
de comenzar el análisis les recuerdo a
los televidentes que pueden hacer
preguntas o dejar sus comentarios en
nuestras redes sociales france24
s con la etiqueta numeral el debate
efe 24
quisiera comenzar con verónica arias
directora ejecutiva del cc 35 que son
los organizadores de este foro para que
nos hagan un rápido resumen de los
puntos esenciales de esta declaración de
santiago
podemos bautizarla como el acuerdo de
parís de las capitales americanas
gracias.marina efectivamente el día de
ayer fue un evento muy fructífero dentro
de las condiciones que tenemos a nivel
mundial fue un evento virtual pero
pudimos interactuar y participar muchos
de los aliados estratégicos y las
ciudades pudieron debatir sobre
y lo que se está construyendo que es la
declaración de santiago me gusta mucho
que se pueda llamar si se puede un
acuerdo de parís pero más que nada es
una ratificación por parte de las
ciudades que
quieren comprometerse y quieren apoyar a
los países justamente en la construcción
de llegar a las metas del acuerdo de
parís creo que es un tema histórico
definitivamente ha habido muy pocas
momentos en la historia de la convención
de cambio climático donde el rol de las
ciudades han jugado un papel
preponderante en la primera creo que
podemos resumir en el 2015 una gran
cantidad de ciudades ratificaron de
alguna forma el acuerdo de parís porque
acordémonos que las partes de la
convención son los países pero las
ciudades que quisieron expresar esa
buena voluntad de contribuir
definitivamente a las a los compromisos
nacionales determinados justamente con
acciones concretas como son las que
pueden llevar a cabo la ciudad es la
otra que podríamos decir es que en el
2012 cuando estados unidos no firmó o no
suscribió el protocolo de kioto
en los alcaldes de eeuu hicieron público
el apoyo justamente a que si el gobierno
federal no estaba pues apoyando el
protocolo de kioto las ciudades y lo
iban a hacer entonces vemos que a nivel
global el liderazgo el liderazgo de las
ciudades cada vez es más importante en
el día de ayer dentro de la declaración
de santiago se manifestaron varios temas
primero el acuerdo de parís es uno de
los ejes estratégicos para llegar al
carbono neutralidad del 2020 50 y ese ha
sido uno de los principales retos y
compromisos al que las ciudades se están
suscribiendo también a adherirse a una
iniciativa que es alcaldes por el clima
y que justamente está en ese marco que
estamos hablando a través de una
legislación marina y esto es muy
importante porque se puede entender
planes se puede tener una voluntad
política pero si no tenemos un
instrumento vinculante especialmente a
través de
ordenanzas municipales o cualquier
instrumento de legislación mal podemos
llegar a las metas que está establecido
el acuerdo de parís otro los grandes
proponentes y de los temas que se
trataron en la declaración de santiago
es ir hacia ciudades capitales sin
plásticos no estamos viendo que uno de
los graves problemas a nivel mundial es
la contaminación por plásticos así que
también se trató de ese tema y el
tercero que es la igualdad de género es
otro de los temas transversales que
vemos cada vez más importante es que la
crisis climática que estamos viviendo
porque ya no es solamente un cambio
climático sino una crisis climática y
vamos a una emergencia climática si es
un llamado que se está haciendo por
parte de las ciudades a las autoridades
nacionales es también que está afectando
a los más vulnerables a los sectores más
más más pobres y por supuesto entre
ellos está el
las mujeres así que de todas maneras ese
es otro tema que tenemos que ir
desarrollando y que es uno de los
acuerdos que las autoridades ambientales
de las américas han puesto sobre el
tapete y que se han comprometido a
trabajar en estos ejes estratégicos y es
uno de los temas de los que vamos a
hablar también en este debate acerca del
rol de las mujeres en la lucha contra el
cambio climático este tipo de encuentros
ambientales a nivel local son mucho
menos conocidos o publicitados sin
embargo pueden dar resultados mucho más
rápidamente que las cumbres globales de
los gobiernos nacionales
santiago de chile- y guatemala son los
anfitriones de este año y del que viene
como las anfitriones como los países
anfitriones y como las ciudades
anfitriones más bien cuál es su opinión
acerca de la importancia de la
gobernanza subnacional en este tema
vamos primero con la jefa de medio
ambiente de santiago isabel aguilera
muy buenas tardes efectivamente la
importancia del gas
acción local de los gobiernos locales en
latinoamérica y sobre todo en chile ha
quedado demostrada entre muchas otras
cosas luego de estos meses duros de
trabajo en contra de la pandemia han
sido las voces de los alcaldes y
alcaldesas de chile las que han
levantado el arroz sobre la urgencia del
trabajo que y las decisiones que hay que
tomar en momentos críticos en momentos
de búsqueda de resiliencia y de
encontrar soluciones efectivas que
puedan dar cuenta de un bienestar de la
población
vamos cuál es la opinión desde ciudad de
guatemala maría josé avendaño
bueno creo que el gobierno local tiene
un vínculo más cercano con la población
y a través de esas normativas como lo
decía veronica podemos contribuir más y
eficientemente a generar estos cambios
que necesitamos no podemos olvidar que
definitivamente las ciudades somos lo
que más impacta moss al cambio climático
por lo tanto somos la herramienta
perfecta para poder llegar y solucionar
estos temas
este tipo de encuentros con de
autoridades locales facilitan esa
comunicación entre las ciudades y
facilitan el aprender unas de otras las
herramientas que mejor han funcionado
creo que si logramos como ciudades
capitales poner este ejemplo de un
trabajo en conjunto vamos a lograr esos
cambios tan necesarios más ratios uno de
los temas recurrentes durante el foro en
cada uno de los aspectos tratados será
la financiación cómo hacer que este
dinero de los presupuestos nacionales
llegue hasta los gobiernos locales jose
luis samaniego desde desde chile desde
la cepal
qué tal muy buenas noches muchas gracias
por la invitación mira para que llegarán
esos recursos nacionales hacia las
ciudades tú tendrías que garantizar que
los gobiernos locales puedan por lo
menos pagar una parte de lo que de esta
manera concertada en rey nación y ciudad
se invierte en alternativas pero eso a
su vez requiere de un fortalecimiento de
los catastros a nivel local para poder
recaudar los impuestos prediales que son
los más fuertes dentro de las finanzas
públicas locales pero tendrías también
que explorar y eso está muy poco
explorado una serie de alternativas
fiscales como los derechos y los
aprovechamientos que las ciudades
podrían utilizar de un modo alternativo
a los impuestos que como un ejemplo para
que se entienda mejor en muy pocos
sistemas de movilidad pública de américa
latina está concesionado el uso del
suelo alrededor de las terminales por
ejemplo de los camiones o del metro de
modo que se conviertan en zonas de
servicios eso ocurre espontáneamente
pero si fuera una decisión ordenada de
los gobiernos esos espacios podrían
generar recursos para los gobiernos
locales que les permitirían re pagar por
lo menos una parte de las inversiones
que se han hecho en esos sitios igual
que recuperando plusvalías por efecto de
la obra pública tú sabes que el suelo se
revalora por efecto de la intervención
pública entonces fortaleciendo estas
áreas de las finanzas públicas e
innovando en el tipo de servicios tú
podrías lograr que el gobierno nacional
se animará más hacen inversiones junto
con el gobierno local porque habría
forma de que esos servicios nuevos y
esas inversiones nuevas fueran
recuperables para el gobierno local
pero entonces desde la cepal qué tipo de
cosas están haciendo ustedes por ejemplo
para ayudar a que este dinero hasta que
este financiamiento le llegue a los
gobiernos locales y puedan entonces
implementar este tipo de proyectos hay
algún proyecto ya en marcha
bueno nosotros ayudamos por ejemplo con
lo que he hecho es ese 35 de generar un
espacio de discusión regional en ir
compartiendo documentando recopilando y
hacer del conocimiento de las
autoridades locales las mejores
prácticas sin duda también a través de
programas de cooperación podemos hacer
llegar financiamiento puntual sin duda
porque no somos una institución
financiera somos una institución de
cooperación técnica para que se puedan
digamos difundir más rápidamente las
mejores prácticas pongo por caso un uno
de los programas de cooperación el
programa de cooperación de la unión
europea hemos convenido con ellos armar
una facilidad de modo que se ayude a las
ciudades a los gobiernos locales a armar
proyectos que puedan llegar a las
ventanillas del financiamiento climático
entonces se sumaría te resumiría
diciendo asistencia técnica haciendo
difusión de las mejores prácticas que
pueden ser absorbidas por las ciudades y
ayudando a llegar a las ventanillas
climáticas del financiamiento climático
para los gobiernos locales en la región
y desde el punto de vista de los
gobiernos locales cuáles son los mayores
obstáculos a los que ustedes a los que
ustedes enfrentan a la hora de encontrar
este dinero para llevar a cabo los
planes y proyectos no soy además no sólo
el dinero sino además llevarlos a cabo
es decir implementarlos vamos con isabel
aguilera primero
bueno en general nosotros presentamos
proyectos de recambio tecnológico o de
mejoras de infraestructura de tal manera
de darle está vía de energía limpia ya
ya nuevas tecnologías que puedan
disminuir la generación de emisiones en
este sentido al ser santiago la ciudad
capital hay una es un gran atractivo es
un pueblo muy atractivo para poder
generar
pilotos
cómo implementar la innovación en la
ciudad para poder generar este
laboratorio
que después se replica en otras regiones
en los financiamientos locales siempre
son muy escasos por lo que indicaba el
señor samaniego que no tenemos grandes
ingresos propios
y generalmente los financiamientos los
hacemos a través del ministerio y el
gobierno nacional hay concursos
periódicamente de incentivar la buena
práctica en términos de acceso a nuevas
energías hay una industria floreciente
en términos de poder
pactar innovación trabajo con academia
en otros pueblos de desarrollo
tecnológico en el país nosotros tenemos
un gran desierto y la potencialidad que
tenemos en materia de energía solar es
infinita
al haber proyectos buenos siempre hay
financiamiento y en ese sentido los
proyectos buenos generalmente van a
generar ahorros en el futuro de consumos
de energía o de otro tipo de consumo y
finalmente los proyectos se van pagando
con los mismos ahorros que van generando
son planificaciones a largo plazo no son
de retorno inmediato entonces debe haber
un financiamiento que soporte el crédito
son instituciones grandes generalmente
las que tienen las espaldas para poder
continuar con este tipo de inversiones
pero es posible es posible con muy buena
voluntad con una capacidad de abrirse a
nuevo negocio ya nuevas formas de hacer
las cosas al interior de la burocracia
estatal
de la burocracia municipal pero también
la voluntad que el privado aprenda a
trabajar con el sector público en un
aprendizaje permanente y de colaboración
tal como lo señaló medio jose con las
otras ciudades capitales de
latinoamérica y me gustaría preguntarle
a verónica arias del cc 35 si dentro de
esta declaración de santiago que según
entiendo es vinculante hay algún tipo de
escritura por la que los cambios de
gobiernos a nivel local no vayan a
afectar a estos compromisos de las
ciudades es decir que no vayan a cambiar
si cambia el gobierno local hay algo así
estipulada
bueno la declaración de santiago es un
instrumento de una voluntad política que
si se quiere se puede seguir lo cierto
suscribiendo es decir el primer foro que
se lo hizo y la declaración de quito se
lo hizo en el 2018 cuando te tuve el
honor de estar al frente de la
secretaría de ambiente de la ciudad de
quito este es de la segunda parte que es
la declaración de santiago y tendremos
en el 2021 dios mediante la declaración
de guatemala y así se van formando los
instrumentos internacionales en base a
la repetición pero no sólo no solamente
eso sino que también lo que se pretende
es justamente que las autoridades
ambientales primero sean empoderadas y
luego que esto sirva de base
precisamente para desarrollar
internamente instrumentos legales
vinculantes es decir leyes normativas
ordenanzas regulaciones que precisamente
ayuden o soporten aquellas metas que
están establecidas
en la declaración suscrita y que será
firmada y elevada hacia los alcaldes y
posteriormente entregada a los miembros
de la cob 26 dentro de la dentro de la
ruta santiago blasco entonces por
ejemplo los mecanismos de financiamiento
que ha sido uno de los temas recurrentes
el día de ayer hay una fuerte necesidad
de todas las ciudades de tener
financiamiento directo para las ciudades
porque como todos sabemos y en el debate
siempre se lo pone en la mesa es que
muchas veces los alcaldes no tienen la
misma línea política que los presidentes
de las de la república entonces están
haciendo que de alguna forma
y dependientes de esa financia de ese
financiamiento si es que hay una buena
relación o no o directamente se da a los
bancos multilaterales por ejemplo se les
da a los gobiernos no a las ciudades es
por eso que se está trabajando en
mecanismos internacionales
por ejemplo en huinca primer plan para
que haya asistencia técnica para las
ciudades para el desarrollo de proyectos
que esto una de las necesidades que
también surgió en el debate de ayer y
también el primer punto si se quiere su
nacional climático con iniciativas donde
el sector privado estaría poniendo un
gran número y un gran capital para
apoyar a las ciudades directamente esto
es de los sistemas novedosos que se está
trabajando a nivel internacional del
cual se ese 35 es parte sigue trabajando
con las ciudades para la generación de
proyectos a ser presentados en
este tipo de fondos financieros no
tradicionales digamos así a nivel
internacional y ahí se demuestra un poco
la importancia de las alianzas
público-privadas de financiamiento para
poder llevar a cabo este tipo de
proyectos nos quedan pocos minutos de
programa se pasa volando el tiempo y
quería hablar de uno de los mayores
enfoques en este tipo de eventos
climáticos que es lo que se llama la
neutralidad de carbono es decir que los
países o las ciudades no emitan más
gases contaminantes de los que son
capaces de absorber uno de los mayores
emisores en ciudades es el transporte
terrestre
santiago que ha sido nombrada capital
verde de las américas durante este foro
es la segunda capital del mundo después
de beijing con más buses eléctricos sin
embargo el transporte público que ha
sido siempre la apuesta para reducir
emisiones ha sido uno de los sectores
más afectados durante la pandemia como
poder restaurar la confianza del público
en el transporte público precisamente
vamos con isabel aguilera en chile'
bien en general
el transporte público se detuvo durante
todo el tiempo de pandemia fue muy poco
el movimiento que hubo tanto en mes en
metro subterráneo como en bus e en
superficie pero justo
cruzo con el recambio que ha estado
ocurriendo de los últimos ya décadas de
incorporación de buses eléctricos que
tiene algunos sistemas de protección que
son tanto novedosos y que han logrado
digamos generar algún tipo de esperanza
para que cuando la gente retorne al
trabajo de manera masiva puede hacer un
poco más seguro poder moverse por la
ciudad nosotros contamos con cobre es un
mineral muy importante en nuestro país y
el cobre tiene una protección y
desinfección es importante en muchos
espacios públicos que están cubriéndose
con cobre para poder generar algún tipo
de desinfección pero también tiene que
ver con un tema de confianza de que la
gente vaya poco a poco retornando a la
vía normal en la medida que se pueda que
los horarios sean flexibles que los
niños no vuelvan al colegio todavía ni
las universidades tampoco de tal manera
de que el regreso sea paulatino de a
poco en distintos horarios evitando
generar horas punta-- de ida y de
regreso que la vida termine más temprano
en la ciudad para no tener que andar a
oscuras por un tema de seguridad también
y también tiene que ver con el aspecto
anímico de la gente en la medida que la
gente se vaya sintiendo más segura va a
poder ir generando mejores en
situaciones de confianza respecto de su
desenvolvimiento natural hay
[Música]
posibilidades importantes
en nuevas tecnologías que se están
incorporando y el cuidado del
autocuidado el uso de mascarillas
barbijos como dicen ustedes
el uso de guantes el uso de alcohol y el
lavarse las manos en general tener un
autocuidado mucho más fuerte
y tratar de ver
tomar el recuerdo con la calma de sí y
obviamente también hay que hacer un
esfuerzo asumo desde las ciudades para
promover otro tipo de transporte como
por ejemplo la bicicleta lo hemos visto
en muchas ciudades de latinoamérica en
buenos aires en bogotá donde estaba
france24 donde las ciclovías se han
aumentado considerablemente los
kilómetros y en muchas ciudades están
pensando hacer las permanentes quería
finalizar con un tema del que habíamos
hablado brevemente al comienzo y es que
incluso durante las protestas ciudadanas
contra el cambio climático una de las
premisas que se repite es la justicia
justicia social y la imposibilidad de
existir sin justicia ambiental hoy en el
programa de hoy tenemos a tres invitadas
mujeres que suelen ser las más afectadas
en los desastres o crisis climáticas
como bien lo decía una de nuestras
invitadas anteriormente sin embargo cada
vez hay más mujeres que lideran también
esta carrera por buscar justicia
ambiental y social cuál es su postura al
respecto y vamos a ciudad de guatemala
con maría josé avendaño
bueno creo que el camino no lo hemos ido
abriendo poco a poco es inevitable
tratar de no ver que la justicia
ambiental la necesitamos que necesitamos
hacer un cambio de comportamiento un
cambio de vida un cambio de como vivimos
y cómo exploramos las cosas creo que la
mujer es vital en ese sentido tenemos
esa capacidad de dar el ejemplo de poder
venir y me forjar metas y cumplirlas
entonces yo creo que es el liderazgo que
se ha estado ganando a través de las
mujeres a nivel mundial no solo mujeres
sino que también niñas tenemos grandes
ejemplos de niñas que son líderes a
nivel mundial en cambio climático' y ahí
es donde hemos ganado espacio donde
creemos que con el esfuerzo de todas
podemos seguir siendo el ejemplo y
poniendo las pautas para mejorar la
calidad de vida y para realmente tener
un futuro donde podamos seguir
tanto de las bellezas naturales pero
sobre todo obteniendo esta calidad la
ciudad de guatemala está sumamente
orgullosa de ser la sede del tercer foro
de autoridades ambientales creo que es
el tiempo para consolidar cada uno de
los foros ha tenido su importancia del
foro en quitó fue el inicio de esta
importante carrera
el foro de santiago lo consolida pero el
foro ciudad de guatemala en el 2020
queda en este camino a la cop 26 y es
donde los gobiernos locales podemos
formular y poder presentar
acciones claves y sustentadas para que
este cambio climático sea afrontado de
una forma liderada por las ciudades y me
gustaría finalizar haciendo un poco una
ronda de comentarios o de mensajes o de
ideas acerca de que necesitamos
realmente en el continente americano
para poder avanzar en la lucha contra el
cambio climático desde abajo hacia
arriba comencemos con jose luis
samaniego de la cepal
muchas gracias marina mira yo creo que
son tres cosas la declaración es muy
importante en el sentido de que genera
un espacio de discusión y llama a una
estrategia regional común eso es básico
hay muchas cosas para armonizar muchas
cosas que aprender segundo yo creo que
en el campo regulatorio los gobiernos
locales tienen un enorme campo
experimentación
y generar condiciones para que la
inversión privada pueda florecer en
alternativas bajas en carbono y tenga
que poner un ejemplo nada más sabemos
que nos estamos moviendo a la
electrificación bueno es necesario que
los gobiernos locales permitan a través
de instrumentos regulatorios que entren
a la circulación los autos son los voces
que van a estar reconvertidos de
combustión interna a eléctricos ahí en
ese campo regulatorio hay un enorme
mundo por por avanzar entonces que
existe el espacio que haya acción
regional que como tú decías tiene más
viabilidad es y que los gobiernos
locales exploren su potencial
regulatorio para atraer el capital
privado la inversión y los consumos
alternativos a las que hay por supuesto
descarbonizar el transporte básico en
las ciudades en 30 segundos maría josé
avendaño su conclusión o su petición
bueno como bien lo decía
[Música]
esto es clave las ciudades tenemos las
herramientas las ciudades tenemos la
capacidad de formular estas normativas
pero también tenemos la cercanía con las
personas y el ejemplo para poder
llevarlas a cabo
en las ciudades están los mayores retos
está el transporte está el agua está la
basura entonces creemos que
definitivamente en las ciudades son
vitales para poder llegar a la
descarbonización y a la disminución de
la temperatura del mundo
vamos con isabel aguilera en chile
creo que el gran desafío para estos
tiempos que se vienen
es un compromiso acabado es decidido es
trabajar por la resiliencia de las
comunidades creo que es súper importante
poder formar comunidades empoderadas y
comprensivas con una muy buena educación
ambiental de que se puede enfrentar un
nuevo mundo una nueva forma de vivir
pensando en consumir menos pensando en
consumir mejor pensando en hacerse cargo
de los residuos que generamos de
recuperar la naturaleza
y el valor que ella tiene sobre todo en
estos tiempos de digamos de
confinamiento y en ese sentido darle
poder a las mujeres para que puedan
generar
alianzas en comercio sustentable en la
incorporación de nuevas energías
y en generar comunidades con mayor
sabiduría pues muchísimas gracias me
disculpo con verónica arias de cc 35
porque se nos acaba el tiempo quedó
pendiente para su conclusión en otro
momento muchísimas gracias a todos los
invitados y a ustedes gracias hay mucho
más en france 24 punto com
[Música]